مع الذكرى الاولى للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا سلطت مجله الضوء على
اهم الدروس المستفاده من تلك الحرب التي
غيرت العالم وقد تكون حرب الصين وتايوان
محتمله في المستقبل
الامين العام السابق لحلف الناتو اندرس
فوجرس موسن قال انه من المستحيل عدم عقد
مقارنات بين هجوم روسيا على اوكرانيا
وطموحات الصين في تايوان وقال ان العواقب
العالميه المترتبه عن الحرب في تايوان
اكبر ومن شانها ان تجتذب دولا اخرى بسرعه
تقع كل من اوكرانيا وتايوان خارج
التحالفات المعاهدات الرسميه ولا تستفيد
اي منهما من ضمان امني كالماده الخامسه من
حلف الناتو ما يجعل الامر اكثر اهميه بان
يتعلم العالم الدروس الصحيحه من الحرب في
اوكرانيا في الفتره التي سبقت الحرب كشف
بوتين عام 2021 عن طموحاته بان السياده
الحقيقيه لاوكرانيا ممكنه فقط بشراكه مع
روسيا وقبل ايام من بدء العمليه العسكريه
وصف اوكرانيا بانها جزء لا يتجزا من تاريخ
روسيا
يقول الراسموس انه لا يمكن للعالم ان
يرتكب نفس الخطا مع الصين التي يجب ان
تؤخذ تهديداتها على محمل الجد
احد الدروس المستفاده هو ان الردعه سيفشل
ما لم تكن الرسائل قويه وموحده قبل بدء
الحرب لذا يجب توضيح العواقب الاقتصاديه
للتحرك ضد تايوان لبكين من الان خصوصا مع
اعتمادها بشكل حاسم على الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها للحصول على الرقائق الدقيقه
الاكثر تقدما فضلا عن ذلك يجب على الحلفاء
العمل معا فقد اظهر العالم وحده مثيره
للاعجاب ردا على حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا لم
يتوقعها بوتين حيث تم الاتفاق على عقوبات
كبيره في وقت قياسي يتعين على الصين التي
تعتمد اكثر بكثير من روسيا على سلاسل
التوريد العالميه ان تفهم ان اي هجوم على
تايوان من شانه ان يشعل ردا موحدا بنفس
القدر هذا الى جانب اهميه توافر الاسلحه
فالمساعدات العسكريه الضخمه التي تقدمها
واشنطن في الاغلب هي التي غيرت الواقعه
على الارضي في اوكرانيا فلو كانت كييف
تمتلك هذه القدرات قبل الحرب لربما فكر
بوتين مرتين قبل شن عملياته العسكريه وهو
سيناريو قد يحدث في تايوان رش خياط
العربيه